hausse du nombre de saisines de la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés la cnil
elles ont bondi de 27% en 2019 pour
attendre exactement elle 14 1137 plainte
selon le rapport d'activité annuel de
l'institution publié hier
environ un tiers de ses saisines sont
liées à la publication de données
personnelles sur internet 10,7 pour cent
porte sur la surveillance des salariés à
la vidéosurveillance sur le lieu de
travail concentre le plus de plaintes
est selon à la cnil et pour en parler
justement on retrouve l gérard haas
avocat et spécialiste du numérique
bonjour gérard haas merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors tout
d'abord est ce que vous êtes étonnés par
la hausse de ces plaintes et qu'est ce
que ça révèle concernant à la protection
de nos données alors je suis pas du tout
étonnée c'est le phénomène rgp des qui
montre sa sa force sa passe a son
importance pour les français les
citoyens même européen
c'est la deuxième année et ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que déjà
l'année dernière il y avait eu une
augmentation de plus de 28% et cette
année il ya encore sur ces 28 % une
augmentation de 27%
ça c'est la première chose donc ces
chiffres sont très importants mais la
hausse elle concerne pas que les
plaintes elle concerne aussi les
sanctions
et puis le la désignation du nombre de
délégués à la protection des données
alors justement gérard haas la hausse de
ces plaintes et de ces sanctions est ce
que ce n'est pas justement le signe que
les citoyens sont prêts à agir pour la
protection de leurs données personnelles
alors oui vous avez parfaitement raison
ça prouve que les citoyens aujourd'hui
sont extrêmement concernés par la
protection de leurs données personnelles
on le voit c'est les plaintes donc c'est
cette augmentation de 27 % des plaintes
qui représente 14 1137 plaintes
essentiellement sont liées à la pour
plus d'un tiers la publication des
données personnelles c'est à dire
qu'elles sont elle concerne l'identité
les problèmes de photographies de vidéos
sur internet mais également toutes les
questions sur les moteurs de recherche
les réseaux sociaux les sites personnels
la presse en ligne et dans les annuaires
et puis parmi ces plaintes viennent à
422 qui sont relatives à des questions
de déréférencement
et là ça présente aussi une augmentation
de plus de 13% par rapport à 2018
également le rôle aussi de la cnil c'est
de trouver des solutions
et là-dessus aussi le pourcentage est
très intéressant puisqu'il est de plus
de 98% des cas qui sont transmis à la
cnps mines
des solutions sont trouvées voilà ce qui
est ce qui a mené au niveau des plaintes
on peut on peut aussi indiquer les
secteurs qui sont essentiellement
touchées
vous avez dans parmi les plaintes c'est
le domaine de l'internet et des
télécommunications pour 34%
ddd plainte le secteur commercial 23% et
le secteur du travail 18% les questions
maintenant elles sont liées notamment à
la surveillance pour le dans le domaine
du travail sur la surveillance des
salariés et des questions de
vidéosurveillance alors selon la cnil
cette hausse est liée à l'entrée en
vigueur du règlement général de la
protection des données le rgp des mamies
2018 est-ce que vous pouvez justement
nous expliquer ce lien
bah écoutez ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'à partir de 2018
la souveraineté numérique de la france
et la protection de ces données est
devenue un objectif essentiel et à
partir de ce moment là les entreprises
ont dû se mettre en conformité et
apporter en es tu dans une démarche
probatoire ce qu'on appelle la
comptabilité et devait apporter la
preuve qu'il faisait tout le nécessaire
pour se mettre en conformité en tenant
des registres un désignant des diplômes
et donc tout ce phénomène montre qu'
aujourd'hui non seulement il y à des
entreprises se mettent en conformité
mais le public aussi est extrêmement
sensible à tout ça et n'hésitent pas à
faire des recours on a aussi la
possibilité d'avoir des actions
collectives et c'est aussi le phénomène
de la sanction vous avez constaté que on
a eu des sanctions qui dépasse les 50 et
1 million d'euros et dont
là dès le début de l'année 2019 google
avait été condamné pour 50 millions
d'euros
et parce qu'il ne respectait pas la
politique de consentement donc tout ça
est lié et ça prouve aussi que
aujourd'hui les entreprises les
organisations ne peuvent pas ignorer une
démarche de qualité en matière de
données et de respecter les règles on le
voit aussi c'est un point issue c'est
cette question des violations des
données est un enjeu crucial pour créer
de la confiance dans l'économie
numérique
alors gérard haas la vidéo surveillance
un des postes de travail ou des lieux
pose un concentre le plus de plaintes
selon ce rapport est ce que ces données
sont inquiétantes selon vous elles sont
effectivement en fait si vous voulez la
question elle est de savoir c'est c'est
d'éviter les espionnages les on est prêt
à partager nos données on est prêt à
accepter certaines positions
mais encore faut-il que cela ne se fasse
pas à notre insu et de toute manière
dans tous les cas dans matière de donner
mon silence ne vaut pas consentement
s'il faut me le demander et si jamais je
n'ai pas dit oui c'est non ça c'est des
points importants et on voit que dans
les grands chantiers que propose la cnil
pour 2020 on a deux questions
essentielles
la première c'est la reconnaissance
faciale et la seconde elle porte sur les
cookies et on voit ça nous concerne tous
et nous nous devons être extrêmement
vigilants et la cnil est là pour si vous
voulez jouer le vigile dans cet
environnement qui pourrait être
dangereux si on n'a pas la main sur nos
données merci beaucoup gerra avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et
spécialiste du numérique merci beaucoup